merrell's two and six this year he's
made 12 starts a 5-1-2 era
fastball cutter curveball changed
fastball's about 92 on average at home
here at chase field he's 1-2 with the
3-8-2 so he's pitched much better here
at home 1-1
and slipped it into right
pretty well again but back is paving
smith under it he takes care of it three
up three down goes the angels in the
first inning now the diamondbacks get to
look at ohtani pitch honey making his
ninth start of the year a 2.76 era and
42 in the third innings
60 strikeouts for the right-hander a
very clean whip of 1.157
ohtani on the mound
there it is that had a true change-up
effect with it as well down goes martay
and the one thing we've noticed this
year from shohei orton especially over
the stretch of the last four starts
he's taking a little bit more off his
splitter now you can still get at 88 to
90 range but this has generally been
sitting around 85 to 87 with a split
doesn't matter you have to make contact
split-fingered fastball struck him out
and a quick clean inning for ohtani
as he picks up a pair of strikeouts
we've completed one there's no score
agents and diamondbacks
called strike three greg gibson rings
him up for a strikeout for merrell
county shortstop number four right there
at the bottom of the zone for merrell
he's been very good in the strike zone
himself in the early going spotting that
fastball right down there at the bottom
of the kneecaps for strike three one two
on the way
golfed out to left center it's hanging
up there
oh david peralta
no freight train on the tracks that's
out number two
quick and a miss back to the sinker
harold kelly six up six
down splitter they want to know if he
went around
yes
you know the fastball velocity you may
give up a couple miles per hour you get
ahead of the count because then you were
able to throw the splitter
and it's lights out
last six games he's been able to help
he's got five hits he's got a double on
base of over 300 333.
he was ready for it high fly ball deep
left field to the corner it goes
aloha it's a home run for suzuki
well he was looking on that inner half
the entire at that and kurt suzuki
[Applause]
second home run of the year
turns on that two seamer inside he got
his pitch and he didn't miss it
here's shohei
wow oh boy he fouls it off that leg
down in a pile same aggressive swing but
the pitch was in
and you knew he was going to do that for
seymour try to cut a fast ball in after
swing like that on a breaking ball here
are the perils two of a two-way player
right
because when you try and get the blood
flowing get it feeling better and you're
the d8 you can sit take care of it
and that's off the knee area
i thought it missed the way it went off
it was going to foot where he has some
protection that's right off his knee
counts two and two
two outs in the ending one nothing
angels in the third the next delivery
that's ripped into right center field
and that is going to go all the way out
to the wall this might score upton just
getting the ball back to the infield
area is smith and upton will score and
chohay delivers right there
he has an rbi double it's two nothing
angels
he did inflict some damage
he did and he could jog into second base
where this ball is hit splits the gap in
right center field it's another fastball
and they did try to come right back
inside
this time shohei says all right i'm
going to get my hands inside this
baseball pulls his hands in splits the
gap in right center field
he's still flexing that leg
rendon hits it hard into center field
shohei makes the turn come on down
the angels at another and they lead it
three to nothing over the diamondbacks
there's a lot to like about that swing
for anthony random one b and he gets an
rbi single and he allows choi to come
around and score and then rest a little
bit before taking the mound
shohei even with that sore knee with
that stride he easily scores without a
throw
and he's been really hot
pounds that one off the plate
charging in fielding firing and a nice
play he was swung around defensively
iglesias
two outs but a huge play on what could
have been another luck hit
is he buying it though with that leg is
he buying the splitter let's see
2-2
99 miles an hour and down goes cabrera
bottom of the fourth with a
three nothing lead but
things getting a little dicey here
runners at second and third here's the
next pitch and he got him to chase a
high fastball through it by him big out
right there struck him out
and ohtani in the game now with his
fifth strikeout the one-two
breaking ball got him break him out and
that will end the inning back-to-back
innings the diamondbacks leave runners
at second and thirds
tony making his way the third time
through this order now
so far this year opponents hitting 136
against him third time through
and a bulk is called for shohei
joe madden wants an explanation
let's see here
i'm not so sure i saw anything he
stepped off
the one two quick pitched him that was a
splitter that was caught
i mean this is
so
you you said he quick pitched him that
means they called the balk because
they're saying he didn't come set
and didn't pause long enough
let's see we'll see if he came to a
complete stop
how is that not a complete stop but i
don't understand with that call right
there that's two of them two on edwardo
escobar
mattel really making a lot of noise down
there at third
that's gets away here comes martay
escobar is at first and it's a 3-2 ball
game
two blocks in the inning now a strikeout
in the wild pitch
[Applause]
the 2-1
blind in the center field
what'd you say about kurt suzuki
what a huge add-on run it's 4-2 kurt
suzuki is three for three continues to
love chase field
christian checks it at 198 with two home
runs
drop the third rendon coming home
it's off the glove of suzuki and
carson's in it's four to three rendon
fields it and throws as he's running
toward home
plate he just clanked the ball off the
mitt right there one-two pitch to the
diamondback lead off hitter josh rojas
swinging a shot to center field it's a
base hit
walking home his ahmed to tie the game
stopping at second is
christian walker we're knotted at four
ohtani doubled and scored in the third
inning drove in a run
bounds that one off the wall big time
top spin how did he hit that one hard
having fun out there that's your
starting pitcher
[Applause]
that one kicks away far enough away for
the halos to
by the way that is an outstanding read
by justin upton we know he's quick but
he read that one in the dirt not that
far away
from kelly at the plate but he read that
one perfectly two down in
eduardo trying to take him deep three
balls two strikes to pay off pitch fly
ball to right hit pretty well back at
the wall and this one is gone
we're tied a two out home run by escobar
ties it at five hero the ninth inning
a 3-2 pitch
he hung him a changeup
right in the happy zone and eduardo put
a great swing probably his best swing of
the night on it and knocked it out of
here well somebody forgot to read the
rules the starting pitcher or any
substitute pitcher in this case ryan
buchter is required to pitch to a
minimum of three batters joe madden came
out of the angels dug out and called
this to great gibson's attention
he's only faced two guys
and so booker goes back out there to
face kurt suzuki through the one out
and now booked her who has blocked and
hit a batter hits another one max has
been crazy good of late
max in on his hands rolls it past the
pitcher's mound and that will play to
run
the 2-2
looks like he got him that'll do it the
angels this wasn't pretty at any point
they won ugly but they'll take it in the
end